desde el estadio de la guerra esta
acería del norte de italia está
paralizada la línea de producción está
cerrada y el horno está apagado desde
hace semanas la razón el acero que se
transformaba aquí venía de ucrania
el acero que venía de mariupol se cocía
en ese horno de allí a 1200 grados hoy
todo se ha parado esta planta pertenece
al grupo propietario de la acería us
hostal en 2021 se procesaron aquí cerca
de 700 mil toneladas de acero ucraniano
este año la última entrega salud de
ucrania el día antes de la invasión rusa
desde entonces nada sin embargo a unos
cientos de metros de aquí la situación
es radicalmente diferente en esta acería
esta es la sucursal italiana de una
colosal empresa siderúrgica rusa
propiedad de un estrecho aliado de
vladimir putin aquí todo sigue igual
desde el comienzo de la guerra puesto
en toda la materia prima de allí viene
de rusia se entrega constantemente ahora
mismo estamos trabajando a tope porque
tenemos muchos pedidos importante con
meses el 15 de marzo la unión europea
decidió prohibir la importación de
productos metálicos de rusia pero el
grupo ha conseguido eludir las sanciones
porque el 51 por ciento del negocio está
registrado en europa los que están
aplicando nuestras sanciones pero en
este caso las sanciones no se aplican
porque los barcos que llegan de rusia
están registrados según la propiedad de
la empresa que aparece como europea y
eso permite que los barcos vayan y
vengan es una buena noticia para la
gente que trabaja aquí y vende
a pesar de que la actividad continúa
aquí todos los que trabajan en el sector
siderúrgico están de acuerdo esperan una
rápida resolución del conflicto en
ucrania para evitar consecuencias en la
industria siderúrgica un sector
estratégico que proporciona más de 70
mil puestos de trabajo en italia